en 2050 le nombre de Canadiens atteints
de troubles neuro cognitifs sévère aura
augmenté de 150% selon une étude de la
Société d'Alzheimer du Canada c'est une
augmentation fulgurante c'est la
première fois qu'on a en fait des
chiffres aussi impressionnants il y a
aujourd'hui 600 000 Canadiens atteints
d'un trouble neuro cognitif si rien ne
change ils seront un million en 2030
puis un million et demi en 2050 c'est
également la même tendance qu'on a au
niveau des personnes précédentes plus de
146% d'augmentation sur une période de
30 ans 350
000 Canadiens consacrent en moyenne 26
heures par semaine à aider leurs proches
en 2050 ils seront trois fois plus
nombreux à le faire pour l'instant il
n'existe aucun traitement efficace pour
soigner cette maladie il y a énormément
de choses qui se passent actuellement en
recherche et donc on s'attend à ce qu'il
y ait quand même quelque chose dans les
cinq prochaines années heureusement
selon l'étude en agissant sur les
principaux facteurs de risque connu de
la maladie isolement social trouble
cardiovasculaire hypertension ou diabète
par exemple on peut aider ceux qui en
sont atteints ce qu'on a remarqué c'est
que quand on gère bien ces facteurs de
risque là c'est qu'on va retarder
l'arrivée de la maladie concrètement ce
délai peut faire toute la différence si
on reporte la maladie de cinq ans c'est
presque 50% des cas d'Alzheimer qui
n'apparaîtrait pas sur le radar de notre
système de santé pour la simple et bonne
raison c'est une maladie du
vieillissement donc on va mourir de
d'autres choses mais au moins on ne
mourrait pas de maladie d'Alzheimer
l'étude indique également que l'épidémie
de trouble neuro cognitifs va frapper
certaines provinces plus que d'autres en
raison de leur démographie différentes
l'Alberta la Colombie-Britannique et
l'Ontario notamment vont connaître une
hausse de cas plus élevée que le Québec
ou les provinces maritimes la Société
d'Alzheimer du Canada estime à plus de 7
milliards dollars la facture annuelle
imputable au traitement des troubles
neuro cognitifs ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal